[Musica]
ricordo ancora quando da bambina iniziai
a scrivere poesie
avrò avuto circa dieci anni
mia mamma spesso mi cercava per casa
insospettita perché diceva che c'era
troppo silenzio poi mi trovava in un
angolino
rannicchiata a scrivere a volte mi
svegliavo anche di notte perché era
troppo forte il desiderio di vedere su
carta certe parole infatti ho ritrovato
quaderni dove addirittura le firmavo
leda tavo giusto per dirvi che l'avevo
presa poco sul serio
poi col tempo ho capito che
io parto rivoli mie poesie
perché nel nostro sistema educativo c'è
davvero poco spazio per parlare di
emozioni di consapevolezza di empatia
quindi per me è la scrittura è sempre
stata un mezzo per comprendere il mondo
ma anche per comprenderli
in mezzo al mondo a scuola spesso ci
chiedevano che cosa vuoi fare da grande
ma io non ho in memoria domande che ci
aiutassero a capire come decifrare le
nostre emozioni
domande come per esempio
hai mai sentito un macigno pesantissimo
qui
sul petto
ricerche scientifiche e psicologi come
gol e mano ad esempio affermano che uno
dei fattori determinanti per il
raggiungimento dei nostri successi
lavorativi e personali e proprio lo
sviluppo dell'intelligenza emotiva e di
abilità sociali e il circle time ossia
il tempo del cerchio è una tecnica molto
semplice di psicologia perché
si dispone in cerchio in modo tale che
tutti abbiano l'attenzione di tutti e
serve proprio per favorire il dialogo e
la cooperazione
non so non vi è mai capitato di essere
al ristorante con amici o parenti
seduti a un tavolo tondo e di pensare
ma quanto è bello mangiare in cerchio
ed è proprio questo che io vorrei
affrontare con voi oggi
perché non passiamo più tempo in cerchio
ad affrontare insieme i nostri macigni
io credo che siamo passati troppo
velocemente da una generazione che ha
provato a non morire di fame ha
soffocato sogni emozioni per mandare
avanti la carretta a un sistema che
alimenta una competizione sfrenata fatta
di numeri di voti di like
e in questo sistema
si tende a perdere l'idea di
collettività di cerchio
appunto
alcolisti anonimi
e il primo cerchio nato in america negli
anni trenta spontaneamente e voi direbbe
sì ma giulia che c'entra io non ho
problemi con l'alcol
infatti qui il punto non è l'alcol il
punto è che per ogni problema che può
sfociare in un malessere una tra le
tante soluzioni che può avere
un'efficacia tale da farci sgretolare
quel macigno e parlare e farlo
apertamente ed è del tutto normale che
all'inizio può risultar c spaventoso del
resto abbiamo passato una vita svolgere
problemi di matematica ripetere a
pappagallo materie per prendere una
sufficienza all'esame non ci siamo mai
messi in cerchio con la consapevolezza
di analizzare noi stessi grazie
all'aiuto dei nostri compagni
inteso è che io credo fermamente che
tutti siamo compagni
e che sviscerare a parole paure dubbi
situazioni che spesso sono comuni a
tutti e può darci quel sollievo qui
sul petto
che ci salva la vita
e allora
la domanda è
perché ci portiamo ancora dietro questo
macigno in famiglia a scuola
lavoro come come se fosse un tesoro
prezioso che non vogliamo condividere
giù le mani dal mio macigno è
sai quanto mi è costato
immagino tanto
io nel 2012 a 22 anni mi trasferivo in
australia
all'epoca andavo alla ricerca di
emozioni da scrivere ma ancora di più
andavo alla ricerca di chi avrei voluto
essere e vi assicuro che la famosa
consapevolezza era una tappa
distante ai miei occhi che infatti un
bel giorno
il meccanismo si blocca
macigno
alla soglia dei trent'anni realizzo che
la mia carriera da export manager non mi
garantisce più un sonno sereno
posticipo la sveglia all'infinito e e
nella mia testa ruotano frasi come ma
dove vuoi andare con la tua scrittura
creativa
con la tua ricerca nel mondo dei tabù
della consapevolezza dell'empatia di
cosa vuoi campare con i tuoi ideali
e davvero i pensieri
tossici
annebbiano la mente e ci servano in
queste gabbie che ci possono togliere la
gioia di vivere
ma io in quel periodo sento che voglio
fare di più e per più persone ma capisco
anche che prima devo partire dal
concretizzare il mio viaggio verso la
consapevolezza di me stessa quindi
deciso di allenare il mio ascolto
interiore attraverso lo studio del
mental coaching della psicologia e
grazie agli insegnamenti della creativa
giulia cameron e qui ve ne propongo tre
di esercizi molto semplici per iniziare
ad allenare il vostro di ascolto
interiore
il primo flusso libero
scrivete ogni mattina tre pagine di
flusso di coscienza libero è
sgrammaticato trattate quelle pagine
come fossero un diario segreto al quale
dedicare tutti i vostri pensieri i
vostri umori vedrete che gettando su
carta certe parole vi renderete molto
più consapevoli di come estate e di come
indirizzare il vostro atteggiamento
durante la giornata
secondo esercizio
la lista delle gioie scrivete sempre di
getto 20 attività chiamate fare poi
vicino ad ognuna la data dell'ultima
volta in cui le avete svolte
e infine sceglietene due come obiettivo
della settimana possono essere anche
semplice una passeggiata in natura
un'uscita con un amico l'importante
ascoltare ciò che amate fare e poi farlo
terzo esercizio il pensiero utile
quando vi rendete conto che la vostra
mente si sta
ingabbiando in quel labirinto di
pensieri negativi e tossici
chiedetevi consapevolmente
questo pensiero mi è utile
se la risposta è no
scegliete di indirizzare la vostra mente
verso qualcosa che vi è davvero utile o
che vi fa stare bene può essere
un'attività della lista delle gioie
oppure può essere anche ascoltare una
canzone che vi riporta benessere o
agganciarvi a un ricordo che vi da buon
umore
l'importante sganciarmi dal loop di
pensieri negativi
quindi
flusso libero
lista delle gioie pensiero utile
insomma in questa ricerca molto
concreta verso la consapevolezza di me
stessa ho deciso di unire le mie due
professioni di scrittura creativa e di
mental coaching per creare una rete di
persone che si fonda su cerchi di
dialogo e sulla volontà di evolversi
come esseri umani attraverso attività
creative che promuovono un linguaggio
sempre più aperto consapevole e
inclusivo immaginate l'ultimo
laboratorio che ho svolto con il mio
collettivo eravamo una ventina di
persone completamente sconosciute
in cerchio in un bellissimo giardino di
pesaro a condividere parole creatività e
soprattutto
cuori aperti per affrontare stereotipi
di genere e discriminazioni nei
confronti dell'orientamento sessuale
insieme
e vi assicuro che questa sorta di
missione sociale che ho intrapreso
ha reso chiaro dentro di me quanto siamo
disabituati al confronto
all'ascolto senza giudizio e al pensiero
creativo ma reso chiaro dentro di me
anche quanto ne abbiamo bisogno
per questo credo che il cerchio sia un
valido strumento per aumentare la
consapevolezza nelle scuole nei luoghi
di lavoro in famiglia ovunque dunque
perché in cerchio la magia avviene
sempre
si sentono frasi come cavolo l'ho
vissuto anche io l'ho provato anche io
allora allora non sono sbagliato
e la magia sta nella connessione
autentica che si accende con l'altro e
che ci permette di scavare ancora di più
dentro noi stessi di liberarci da quel
macigno di ricaricarsi di energia
positiva
perché magari è vero è che nessuno ci ha
mai insegnato come metabolizzare le
nostre emozioni
magari è vero che nessuno ci ha mai
detto che ogni sogno vale la pena di
essere vissuto anche se non ti
garantisce il pane e che se ti senti
diverso
va bene c'è un posto anche per te
ma questo significa semplicemente
che possiamo essere noi la generazione
che cambia questa prospettiva a favore
di una visione
circolare perché ci sono i momenti in
cui non ci riconosciamo più
troppe informazioni
pochi strumenti
troppo rumore
ma la notizia positiva è che siamo
sempre noi a scegliere
quando e come abbassare il volume
siamo noi a scegliere quali strumenti
estrarre dalla cassetta degli attrezzi
per
sgretolare quel macigno
il dialogo
costruttivo
interiore e in cerchio
si fonda su un ascolto senza giudizio ed
è davvero uno degli strumenti più
potenti che abbiamo per accrescere la
nostra consapevolezza
ricordiamoci che
prima di essere lavoratori
siamo esseri umani e soprattutto in
questo periodo di lontananza e di sfide
per la mente e per il corpo
scegliamo di puntare sul essere più
umani
[Applauso]
[Musica]